hello everybody my name is markiplier
welcome back to let's play condemned
oh my YT senses tingling oh that's it
here yeah just like that
alright lemme see hi baby thank you
number 8 subway passenger guard move
searching Oh business registry shows
when was the city's contractor for the
cars years ago yeah I haven't seen one
of these number 8 cars and years get a
close-up of the red circle area it's
hard to say Oh fine geez whatever Clint
can't be easy well enough BAM ah mmm
part ball point B that's all for
tonight's a searing compartment Oh
doesn't Thomas they generally seal the
doors of these suckers shop when they go
out of commission whoa no kidding
try the cars tool cabinet the frame wall
once inside the car I'm that compelled
yes ma'am my crowbar under here or in
here crowbar Grobe
oh darling I don't what the deal is with
everything getting completely washed out
whenever there's white on the screen I
don't know what the deal is with that
probably just in effect the way it's
supposed to be hey Joe what Oh
someone cut someone's head off ready for
what what are you ready for blood
anything on the ceiling I'm not seeing
it what are you ready for Ranch weekly
oh here we go
I'm an idiot oh this looks so strange
terrific every little bit of dust on the
end of the crowbar is a common plaster
mix okay
pigmentation particles mixed in with the
dust are of a soft pinkish okay
apartment store dummy so that's not good
okay I got my Kroll buddy come here baby
I'm gonna get you I'm gonna crack you
open black there nude
oh god damn it Wow how did I miss that
it was friggin Point Blank oh you missed
almost as badly how did I miss that I
did it oh well I'm not gonna miss this
ha ha no we're all swinging a minute uh
those guys are not tough who runs up and
fight someone with a wooden plank I mean
really I mean really who throws a shoe
can't go downstairs slayers fast also
stairs no I'm so fat and out of shape
oh god it's so much work huh Oh Gary Oh
huh so strong strong though but lazy and
very very slow ah nothing here ooh a
footprint that looks highly suspect huh
nope Deb ah wasn't there where I started
compiling into three-dimensional boy
that's fancy
boy footprint size 14 D salt pattern
matches Badgers Footwear protector okay
I'll run a buyer search locally but you
can get these anywhere fairly common
there's some schmutz in the pattern
troughs probably same plaster dust as
before Oh
how do how do they how is their
technology do all of this open
compartment whoa oh no no don't tell me
what to do
Bart's more like farts parts department
store just a minute
I don't like this six four five
Burnside's unfolds is 14 years ago the
squatters group took it over almost
immediately now it's not what you would
call prime shopping yeah makes sense the
matchmaker would be there a good source
of mannequin parts but then what's all
this here an outpost a second shop I
should probably go down there yeah just
don't get carried away
she had the cops don't even drive down
Burnside unless they have to it's a
nasty area of they'll one nasty people
just like the rest of this city
different they go beyond
I'll go to 60 Eckstein Burnside that
train will take you directly to the
department store
why is there a hurry I'll just make it
what why is there no one why is there
nothing but crazies and creepies
everywhere everywhere is crazies this is
a public city any sort of science goes
up in a sec if this is any sort of a
normal kind of city why why is there no
one normal I mean come on I know they're
crazies everywhere like here right here
did you booze
yeah I'm s-sorry I missed your big fat
head I know what's going on oh no nope
oh well yeah lady oh sorry
murder wanton murder head butt yeah but
Dad hurt baby
was it a nice little kiss from me to you
and your face
if I hurry I'll just make it okay we're
gonna run any visor though would be oh
wait no is wrong
what does Oh what uh my very first metal
piece oh this is those people's home I
just totally ruined their lives because
I killed them and they were just trying
to live I mean sure it not great place
but they were trying to quote hello well
hello
that doesn't seem good let's go say hi
oh no I think it hey yeah leave me alone
bye let out three and there's a revolver
here now I keep this is three probably
no bullets in the revolver anyway I'm
making my way back oh you don't jump on
someone who has a shotgun mister oh man
that's turtle
I will say in certain games like this
having a gun kind of helps with the
horror bit not quite as scary when I can
just blow them away with one shout two
budgets it's weird like there's almost
no reload mechanic I don't know if you
can like hold any ammo or what I guess
not yeah like dump it for a new gun
every single time okay here No
yeah this way
wait a minute I got on the right way I'm
not even sure anymore what that way
least I'm trying to go back to where I
was right
ah yes I am I am making it pass through
the door to complete this chapter well
oh yeah five or six Birds really I
didn't think I got that many jeez and
I'll continue oh gee no no no ooh hey
let me read this first thing it has been
determined that birds are drawn to
specific locales throughout the city by
strange sonic disturbances of unknown
origin once in close proximity of the
Sun of a disturbance the bird's brain
suffers immediate and extensive brain
damage that quickly leads to its death
it is not known at this time whether
humans or other life-forms are affected
although there is clearly a connection
between crime-ridden areas and where
birds swarm and die cut scene
Oh what was that yeah
Thomas er Thomas it's for that about it
running from the Puri we don't know shut
up you know we'll find you eventually
understand the case we became too much
you weren't solving cases like he used
to
you're talented high-strung you snapped
it happens sometimes it happened I did
not snap someone else killed those
policemen it looks like it might have
been the matchmaker with you or good it
seems unlikely Disney psychiatric state
if they can help you sort things out
with all due respect I don't need a
shrink
oh ma you guy
I want to rethink your last statement
yeah I have gone crazy
yep that seems pretty unlikely what the
hell whoa oh look
feral it's Malcolm and Longhorn your
balls been bothering you oh yeah yes to
be expected they're not going to let
this drop you must continue with your
investigation they'll understand nope
sharra yes I mean no what do you want
from me Malcolm what's going on going on
weird [ __ ] you are being investigated by
the FBI for the murder of two police
officers that's what's going on right
you will be tested Thomas I'm not you
can be sure there are mannequins in here
excuse me while I grab a weapon ah yeah
rip it right through the I don't even
know where I got that from there are
mannequins are mannequins I do not like
mannequins I'm not gonna grab his arm no
jeez what what
what was that
what was that hi hi hi oh no oh no oh no
oh no oh no oh no
hey going on how did you die leave how
about uh how about you leave now that
sounds pretty good huh I like that idea
I like it a lot was that close right
yeah I'll fight with that names a bit
better anyway oh hey I saw you was you
the one that left that note on the
corpse of your old buddy right
I see yeah idea what you gotta do what
are you gonna do what are you in it
hi who did that
hello anybody out there
all right so far so good getting just a
little bit free here just a little bit
all right
hi
alright then who was that
dammit got more enemies with actual guns
doesn't help hey about it you should
have jumped through the window in the
first place anyway you would've been
shot hello hi hi hi there how's it going
hey buddy
my glad you could uh visit
Oh medal oh ok whenever I see these eyes
that means there's a piece of metal
nearby but why would I need the metal I
don't get it there's like something this
guy's obsessed with stuff that he does
not need like in no way does he need any
of this stuff that he's grabbed dead
birds metal strange strange tissue
samples DNA and whatnot I don't like
this area I don't like it at all
oh look at that bird just dala I'll take
that that's nice that's a nice dead bird
that's like 100 hello ceiling get you
from all the way over here
I did Wow good for me you have a gun
don't you though my bad idea
I don't know I'm actually all at a time
so click on the links over there for
more let's play sad done check out my
reaction compilations and thank you all
so much for watching and as always I
will see you in the next part bye bye
Wow